well
I don't really know much about tuxedos
except for that penguins wear them I
don't know I feel indifferent normally I
would be concerned that I'm not gonna be
able to move my arms because my
shoulders will get stuck but because
this is a men's suit I have a feeling it
might fit my shoulders better no one in
my family really wears tuxes or suits I
just imagine that anything has to be
more comfortable than what women wear I
think it leaves room for you dick cuz
it's like really long in the front
worrying about one part they do do not
have to worry about which is the breasts
I don't know I don't know how to read
boy sizes it's just like 27 30 to 45
it's like oh we do in football plays why
would anyone want to wear this on their
wedding day
this is the most uncomfortable thing I
feel like I look like one of those 1930s
big band singers hey man hey man don't
you let the band play
oh I'm not used to buttoning all the
buttons oh I feel like I'm being
suffocated this you should put in some
motion there's so many things no idea
how to do it this can't fit over my head
you guys wear these oh [ __ ] yeah oh hell
yeah
okay well it kind of looks like I have a
diaper on it's making me realize I
really like the woman's fit on my body
for a tighter pant I always was like oh
guys have it so easy because suits are
comfortable and they can move around and
dresses are terrible because you're
basically like stuck in one position all
night but suits are not comfortable guys
have it bad in just a different kind of
way I guess I wasn't giving guys enough
credit for how they were wearing tuxes
and putting tuxes together because this
was more work than I expected
and it's got pockets oh I look like
Count Dracula